[Music]
oh the first people who inhabited this
island the can people clearly lived in
tandem with
[Music]
nature I grew up in my entire life in
the carago
space I was part of a unique family my
my dad my uncle two cousins before we
all kago
[Music]
chief the carago nation was built around
the ocean built around the sea bu built
around the
[Music]
water the sea was one of the primary
areas of for for resource and so for
food and for travel and and in
resistance of
invasions and and so the sea became part
of
us
[Music]
in Dominica the food the beverage the
architecture all L heavily on the use of
Nature and not only the use of nature
but the the the sustained use of
Nature and all of it was aimed that
ensuring that we
[Music]
survived
everything that we know as Dominicans
what we eat how we breathe how we sleep
how we dance how we sing it's all being
influenced by the environment around
us there's a very motherly role that
exists in the island how she takes care
of us how she raises us how she feeds us
provides for
us she has a life of her
own
hurricane Maria hit the island of
Dominica as a category 5 it's the first
time in recorded history a hurricane
that strong makes landfall on the
island I will never forget get the exact
moment that hurricane Maria hit the West
Coast 2015 we had tropical storm Erica
and in 2017 hurricane
[Music]
Maria the wind was howling so loud and
you couldn't really see anything outside
and then just like that the roof just
started to
go
the key lesson that we've learned from
the impacts of these natural disasters
Erica and Maria is that in a few hours
your entire economy can be wiped away
the country was very
decimated how do you figure out who's
alive because you emerge to this like
nothingness how are people supposed to
survive this
the government realized uh that we
needed to do something
[Music]
drastic that we had to build greater
resilience of Dominica otherwise we
would continue to be stuck in this Build
Destroy rebuild
cycle for us the issue of climate
resilience is actually is an existential
issue it's a matter of survival we are
we will not be able to
survive um if we do not build resiliency
within every aspect within every sector
of of this
country we have one guiding
mission to become the world first
climate resilient Nation by
[Music]
we were invited by the government of
Dominica to assess the health of the
marine
environment because the only way a
country can be resilient to the impacts
of climate change is by ensuring that
their environment is healthy and nature
can help the country come
back and this is where we come in with
our
[Music]
research working with local
Partners to understand what's the status
what's the condition of the coral reefs
the deep sea the offshore Waters of
Dominica Pro
is a program that started in 2009 by Dr
Enrique Salah National Geographic to
help explore and protect the last wild
places in the ocean and we do that
through a combination of science
exploration media and policy by going to
some of the most amazing untouched
places in the ocean and helping them get
protected
we'll begin the expedition in the
Southeast and then head north along the
coast toward kabitz National Park
surveying the waters as we go if we are
lucky a weather window should allow us
to access sides on the rougher Atlantic
side of the island including makuba Bank
a sea mount 20 km off the coast of the
[Music]
we in the ministry are very excited
about this Expedition and the findings
that we are hoping you'll be able to
capture through the the time that you
spend in our
Waters we have not captured some of this
data to the extent that would allow us
to make decisions by 20130 to achieve
the goals that we' set for
ourselves it's a pleasure meet you
there's no substitute for local
knowledge these people who are in the
water every day understand this
ecosystem they understand the rhythms
and
Cycles by combining and collaborating
with local researchers local fishermen
local people who understand the
ecosystem we can bring some of our
assets and then collectively we'll just
do a better job of understanding the
ecosystem and therefore doing a better
job of being able to manage it in the
future
we're here in the southern part of
Dominica by Village of sura and we're in
the Scots head Marine
reserve what we really like to see is
how are the Marine protected areas doing
relative to other areas that are open to
fishing that have other types of impacts
associated with
them a marine protected area is a place
where human activities are reduced so
marine life can come
back the healthier the marine
environment the more resilient it is to
the impacts of climate change and other
human activities and the best way to
restore the health of a marine
environment is through fully protected
areas where damaging activities are
banned and these are the areas that
allow the fullest recovery of marine
life but they also have other benefits
these reserves are so full of fish that
many of them spill over they reproduce
much more and help to replenish the
fishing grounds nearby also when the
fish come back the divers come in and
we've seen from many places around the
world that diving tourism ecotourism
increases after protection supporting
jobs and bringing in much more economic
Revenue to
countries
so that's kind of the three remote
camera systems and then so the dive team
so you're going to be going out with the
dive team and that'll be K and Eric
myself and Jen it's not been a lot of
work done outside of the few protected
areas that Carrie and other people have
worked on so we're really relying on
people like Carrie and a lot of the
other locals to provide that local
knowledge to help us hone in on where we
can provide additional information for
the government to help protect their
marine environment right now that's what
we're
[Music]
tackling I have been a warden now for at
least 10
years it's a fun job it's something that
I have never thought I would be involved
in but once I got a taste of it I've
never looked back and only forward and I
love my my
job we always have to be monitoring this
area there's a trail that will go up
into the bush and will connect to the
main road often times poachers will just
use that and come down to the beach to
do their illegal
activities so this is one of our highly
monitored areas right here point
ginard
[Music]
my job description is actually enforcing
the laws of the Marine reserve which
entails protecting the marine
life also having a great relationship
with the Fisher folks giving information
to tourists and locals about our
conservation
[Music]
work in my 10 years of being a warden I
I will say that it has its ups and
downs you have people that are not
willing to cooperate with the wardens
coaching you might often find yourself
in a in a situation where you could have
uh verbal altercation with a
fisherman it becomes extremely stressful
sometimes but the upside to that is the
fact that we're meeting with different
people from different parts of the
world you actually exchange culture
exchange information and you can
definitely spread the word about
conservation
work it definitely you know raises your
spirit and helps you to go out the next
day because you know what you're doing
is um going to be beneficial for you and
uh for future
Generations the Caribbean has kind has
suffered Death By A Thousand
Cuts all different types of impacts have
occurred in the Caribbean from over
fishing to a lot of coastal development
a lot of Tourism that has negative
impacts landbase source of pollution
poor water quality and things they
get so we're hoping to be able to see
are there still places in the Caribbean
that are healthy and maybe they can help
support
the marine ecosystems
elsewhere I am definitely excited
because we're going to be diving at
Solomon's which is one of the places
where we could definitely see lots of
fish it's very diverse on any given day
you never know what could be passing by
in the blue it just all depends on what
modern nature throws your
way
[Music]
Dominic is a pretty interesting Island
so very geologically active on land and
that kind of extends to the
Sea
there's a lot of interesting geological
features a lot of sea mounts and so
forth and that makes for a a diverse
Marine EOS system anything from the
shallow typical Caribbean carif
ecosystem to some of the deep sea
[Music]
habitats
we found a few places that had really
nice elor caral a CA
pomada they used to be the dominant
thing on Reese in the Caribbean and now
it's really hard to find them so to see
them is a hopeful sign that maybe
they're hanging on and maybe they're
even being able to reproduce and at some
point maybe replenish other
[Music]
areas the first dive is always so educ
ational it was it's it's really going to
set the tone for the rest of the trip so
really excited now um to see the
diversity of the fishes on this reef and
it was actually spectacular it was just
a beautiful little
Reef the good news is that fish in the
reserve are twice more abandoned than
outside but most of the fish are quite
small so there is still potential for a
fuller recovery of marine life within
the reserve
we spent the last couple days in the
Scots head Marine protected area near
the village of
su and now we're going to head our way
North uh towards the center portion of
the island staying on the west coast on
the Caribbean
side and we'll see how that compares
outside the Marine protected area to
areas that are more heavily
fished
if you look at the the geography of
Dominic and where many communities are
located you would see there most of them
are located well within one mile of the
coastline and the basic reason is that
we have always largely depend as a
protein Source on on
Seafood
you see what
happening
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
t as a nation learning from the sea
learning from from the
water we have understood import us of
having that resource at all fingertips
and not only to to use for day Liv but
to learn from
it as a powerful element we have to find
time to understand it and also to
appreciate that it can be managed to our
[Music]
benefit traditionally fishing has been a
very important aspect of dominica's diet
of domin's traditions of Dom's
livelihoods of Dominic's
employment I don't do fish about since I
was about 1550
years I know I about
54 I Fe all my
formality what I
catch managing the fishes in Dominica is
a huge undertaking but as we know in
fishes management we don't manage the
fish we manage the
people we try to work a lot with the
people who actually interact with those
um resources a lot so we meet with them
we have have discussions with them we
train them and we make them understand
the importance of the Marine space and
the resources within the Marine space
and how they should act within the
Marine space so that it can be safe and
healthy for everybody and they
themselves can form and maintain and
sustain a very lucrative livelihood
within that Marine
space we eat what we grow the same fish
that is being protected in the mpa is
what you're going to need for
proteins we need to understand that we
have to do a better job at how we fish
it needs to be um some type of stability
in terms of um what we actually go out
and catch the size of the fish the type
of
[Music]
fish it's not just about conserving
what's taking place within those
protected
areas if these critical areas are
protected then the whole island is going
to benefit from that so even though you
can't fish in that one particular
area you're going to have more animals
they can produce more offsprings that
can benefit the areas outside of that
protected area and be available to
[Music]
fishing
do we're up early because we're going to
makuba bank
today so we're heading about 20 mi off
the coast of Dominica to sample this
kind of rise the same Mount that comes
up we know it's an important place for
fishing for pelagics so we're really
interested in what might be out
there makba bank is sort of a a platform
it's a bank that about 20 mi off the
southeast east side of
Dominica it starts up at around 70 m is
the shallowest area and then it drops
off down to over 1,000 M on the
[Music]
sides makuba bank is an excellent
opportunity for pristine Seas to use our
deep sea
cameras
[Music]
so we're out here today deploying a
range of different
cameras we're deploying mopic cameras on
the sea floor deep sea cameras just off
the edges of the plateau and then uh
pelagic cameras in the Blue Water
above
the deep sea cameras allow us to explore
this habitat this ecosystem that's very
difficult to to know
about it'll give us a good idea of what
animals are out here what impacts they
might be having in terms of fishing from
both dominans and from near nearby
neighboring
countries so the data we're going to
collect out here might help inform
domin's conservation
planning we've moved away from from
Nearshore fishing in many many
communities and we have gone into the
offshore fishing through the use of
[Music]
fads fish aggregating device or fad is
important for essentially bringing the
fish into one little area that you can
actually Target them and catch them it's
important for us here in Dominica
because we largely dependent on large
pic
Fisheries but if a fat now you have a
better chance of making a catch because
you know that they will be fish there in
in most most
cases the fs allows them that
opportunity to go directly to the fish
catch and pinpoint what is available
they catch the fish and they are able to
return on the same day and land the fish
for
sale
it's not very intrusive and it it causes
minimal ham to really the
[Music]
environment this should be a really Lush
productive brief platform slse Mount but
right now there seems to be a lot of
over fishing going on there and so the
bank was not as productive we would have
thought
B spent a solid three days there makuba
Bank probably could benefit from better
management there's a lot of illegal
fishing if that fishing was you know
reduced or eliminated the productivity
of the bank would probably
increase but I have noticed there one
pishy for example the Malin in the
beginning when we started bringing an
unsh the Malin they were very huge they
were very very huge but today they are
either um not brought on Shore they're
not caught they're not available or they
very
[Music]
small there's a a dual benefit there for
both the Open Water mobile species and
also for the resident Reish if they get
protected out at makua bank they'd be
bigger they produce more offspring and
potentially spill over to the adjacent
Nearshore areas that could be harvested
by the Dominica
fisherman
we had this amazing opportunity to have
these SE fellows come on to our
Expedition share their knowledge and
what they know about Dominica and also
have them experience what it's like to
be on a National Geographic pristines
Expedition product C is a marine
educational leadership program that
Dominica
runs taking a measurement every second
so go ahead and start dropping it
down what we do is try to create some
sort of ocean literacy program for our
fellows um we're trying to make sure
that they are youth leaders in the
Marine ecosystem and become sewers of
the
ocean the youth are the future and the
youth need to be fully on board with
ensuring that there is protection of the
environment and we have a responsibility
as adults as well to take the actions
now to will ensure their
future for the pristine Seas Expedition
I'm quite excited to be a part of their
research their experiments to be a
sponge to absorb information as well as
to be able to use that information and
communicate it back to the
public so we just deployed two meso
cameras so fellows at the end of their
cohort they will learn new skills in
research vessel skills seamanship and
sperm whe communication Dominica SP whe
program has been doing research for the
past 15 years and so we are using that
information to better understand how
Wheels
communicates this is a very rare Coral
through this Expedition and being a
setti fellow I'm really looking forward
to delving even deeper into the
science and looking forward to studying
the wheels and understanding their
coders even
[Music]
more
Dominica has something unique in its
Waters a resident population of about
200 sperm
[Music]
Wells we consider them to be citizens of
Dominica they're born live grow up in
our
Waters and that for us is very
important
[Music]
I have been diving for 35 years all over
the world from the Arctic to the tropics
and I had never experienced something
like swimming with the sperm wells in
Dominica it was totally magical and
spiritual sperms communicate among
themselves using clicks which are very
loud you can feel them in your bones
when you
underwater and this is the way they
identify themselves cuz they live in
families materal lineal
[Music]
families this mother whale like other
whales needs two
things she needs a place where food can
be found
reliably and when she has her young she
needs a place that's relatively
sheltered and protected so her babies
are
safe and Dominica has them both
throughout the
year the island this island it's full of
Um mountains and valleys and so and
that's how it is underwater so these
perals the ones that are here are unique
to this island because these whales use
the shores the same valleys and
mountains and so to
feed sperm Wells are the largest of the
tooth Welles they are actually the
largest top predator on the
planet to maintain these bodies these
Giants dive to 800 or 1,000 M deep for
45 minutes to hunt giant
[Music]
squid and in between Dives they come
back to the surface and
rest this is how SPM Wells
sleep they have the shortest sleep cycle
of any mammal on
earth napping for about 15 minutes
before descending again for another
meal we don't know yet why they sleeping
these formations but we do know sperm
Wells are part of the climate resilience
machine of
Dominica along with resting and
breathing when they come back to the
surface in between Dives they
defecate and well poop is very rich in
nutrients that fertilizes the shallow
Waters which creates Blooms of Plankton
these microscopic plants that use
sunlight to capture carbon dioxide from
the water and release
oxygen when this Plankton dies it sinks
to the bottom of the ocean to the deep
sea with the carbon in it which then
becomes a carbon sink
the more Welles in the ocean the more
they will be able to help us mitigate
climate
change so a sperm well Reserve would be
part of dominica's climate resilience
strategy but the sperm Wells of Dominica
have been declining steadily over the
last 20 years because of a combination
of human threats that are not unique to
Dominica the affect sperm Wells
throughout the
planet like ship strikes noise chemical
pollution entanglement with fishing gear
eating
[Music]
[Applause]
plastic currently there are no shipping
lanes to regulate the traffic of large
vessels like cargo ships and Cru ships
in Dominica
Waters and these vessels crease cross
whale territory every single day which
increases the risk of ship strikes and
this is something that affects whales
throughout the
[Music]
world we have a passion for these
animals you
know seen these animals growing up a lot
of times over the years we see the
mothers give birth so we we know these
wheels personally
we need to try to protect these animals
as much as possible so we can have these
wheels 200 years from now you
know a sperm well reserve for
Dominica could include regulations that
basically are the The Playbook and best
practices for everyone to operate within
that works best for the
whales that could be a real pinnacle of
dominica's economy for the long
[Music]
run for the most part there's a lot of
emphasis on the green economy because
it's sort of what you see every
day but there's a massive resource in in
the blue economy in terms of the marine
life the development of the blue economy
is one facet of what we're looking at in
terms of building our
resilience
[Music]
if we can continue to develop it and and
ensure that the marine life is properly
protected then it continues to be an
area of of Interest an area of Wonder I
think for our tourists and also for our
locals as
well we know from places around the
world that the healthier the marine
environment the more it attracts
tourists and the more people are willing
to pay to see that diversity of life in
the
ocean if you can imagine Marine reserves
are like fish factories so starting with
that core you have tourists that want to
see the fish inside the reserve there's
a spill over of fish for sustainable
ftes outside and then from there you can
see the concentric circles of how many
secondary and tertiary markets within a
country benefit from that so of course
people stay in hotels and eat food and
there's all these other local people
that enjoy what the Marine reserve
provides when the ocean is
replenished people are willing to pay
for very special experiences with
amazing creatures so for example the
gorillas in Rwanda at volcano's National
Park people pay $1,500 for just an hour
to hike up and spend a little bit of
time with a gorilla family for a day
which turns into into a lifelong
memory so Dominica has an opportunity to
really highlight its sperm whales in its
country and create a best practice
framework with a destination tour
operators and traveler and price it
[Music]
accordingly land to Sea mountains to the
ocean are all heavily connected and
Dominica so what happens on land can
really affect what happens in the ocean
so we need to think about conservation
not only just in the sea or just in the
land we need to think about conservation
in a more holistic way where
everything's
[Music]
connected so far the effects of global
warming climate change pollution has
already affected Dominica in so many
negative
ways we have seen a drastic decline in
the corals
here and if they are destroyed or they
die off we at risk of seeing a lot more
of the coastal
[Music]
damage Domino like a lot of places are
at a Crossroads or or a Tipping Point
[Music]
all you have to do is go a little bit
over too much fishing too much pollution
too much Coastal development and then we
don't know what's going to happen with
climate change and once things get out
of balance they can tip very
quickly we are aware that in terms of
the population the fish population um
near sh it has gone down significantly
it's urgent and incompetent upon us that
we make the change necessary to make
sure that the species are there
longterm we're going to the Atlantic
side at Scot set drop off and we're
going to treat the P
Coral Marine protection only works if
there is public support for it
the creation or expansion or
modification of any protected area
really relies heavily on community
support and Community input at every
step of the
way an important part of our thrust to
becoming resilient is also ensuring that
there is collective consciousness of all
people ensuring that we are aware of how
our actions impact on others how our
actions impact on the environment and
have having a greater sense of the need
to protect the environment for our
[Music]
future does not matter if we have the
best natural resources in the world and
we do not have the people to do the
necessary Works to take advantage of
these resources then we will not be able
to achieve this goal so people are the
most important assets of the country and
I'll just ask people to reconsider and
to weigh their options
and make the best decision that that is
would be preferred for the development
of our
[Music]
nation Dominica has a unique opportunity
to set the right type of
protections that will restore marine
life improve the fishing catch and the
livelihoods of local
fishermen
and also bring in much more economic
revenue from people who want to come to
the nature
Island to see something that they cannot
see anywhere else in the
Caribbean it is a creature I believe
that we have a duty and an obligation to
protect and so we'll be declaring very
soon Dominica having the first sperm whe
Sanctuary or um or Reserve protecting it
from the Cru ships are coming in
protecting it from the carbo vases
coming in protecting them from the
fishing um and and and this will receive
legislative
protection because it's important for us
to protect that very special creature
and a creature that is so huge but
gentle and a very important source of of
r
for many of our citizens and for our
country as a
[Music]
whole our small island Community here uh
has a lot to offer to humanity in terms
of preservation of Nature and the
environment and and building human
[Music]
capacity Dominicans are very resilient
people
as a very strong vibrant and proud
people because we have been used to
depending on
ourselves I think the most important
thing that we
have is our people I think that's the
greatest asset the resilience of our
people when a disaster happens or
anything happens in normany we get up
next morning and we start
working we are seeking to create
solutions for ourselves we're saying
okay the the Hurricanes will come but
we'll prepare for them and we'll become
more resilient and and so that the
destruction that that the hurricanes
have caused in the past we will not
suffer the same level of Destruction in
the future hurricanes coming to the
Caribbean from the Eastern Atlantic and
all of these islands in the ANS are in
the middle of the hurricane highway so
Dominica is susceptible to being hit by
a hurricane every number of
years we have been able to do quite a
lot in domica so far there was
infrastructure that we built after
Tropicals St Erica that was able to
withstand the might of Hurrican
Maria so we know that it is
possible
[Music]
My Hope for Dominica is that we will
continue to be an island that is known
for its respect for the environment for
[Music]
sustainability that Dominica will be The
Shining Light for the rest of the
Caribbean of a country that employs
clean and green practices and is able to
do well as a
[Music]
result we don't believe that we can save
the entire world now but if each of us
were to play our small part in the small
space that we have then it all adds up
and the world can be a much better place
for all of us to live in and and for
citizens to be able to stay where they
are and to become economically
[Music]
empowered I don't even believe we're the
nature island of the Caribbean I believe
we're the nature island of the
world it is definitely a breathtaking
experience everywhere you go on land in
the water we have have so much to
[Music]
offer there are so many places that are
still untapped still
undiscovered we want to just explore
with you enjoy everything that we have
and the only way that we can do that is
to to preserve
[Music]
it the island itself will take care of
us once we take care of
[Music]
it